samedi à 15h15 sur public sénat
françois bayrou le président du modem le
mouvement démocrate est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous au françois hollande a
épuisé son crédit auprès de vous du coup
vous revoilà à la tête d'un vaste
chantier la reconstitution de la famille
du centre avec jean louis borloo vous
nous donnerez certainement au cours de
cette émission la date du mariage en
approche
le constat vous paraîtra cruelle par
ailleurs françois bayrou c'est marine le
pen qui a réussi à faire exploser la
bipolarisation en france en imposant en
tous les cas c'est ce que disent les
sondages le front national comme premier
parti de france à vérifier bien sûr lors
des prochains scrutins
les municipales et surtout les élections
européennes avec moi ce soir
raphaël hermano de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire avec
dailymotion
et puis perrine tarneaud bien sûr de
public sénat pour la troisième partie de
l'émission vos critiques se font acerbes
françois bayrou contre la politique
engagée maintenant depuis 18 mois est ce
que vous avez atteint un point de non
retour après avoir voté pour françois
hollande
j'ai fait crédit à françois hollande
pendant 18 mois en pensant qu'il
tiendrait les promesses qu'il avait
faites parce que ce sont ces ses phrases
ses mots
le la politique économique au service de
l'entreprise la politique de l'offre le
retour à l'équilibré le fait en 2013
les finances publiques retombé au
dessous de 3% et le fait qu'il allait
entreprendre la moralisation des gens
qu'ils ont engagé un blé non non non les
chantiers ne sont pas engager les
réformes promises ne sont pas au rendez
vous il n'est que de voir on a voté cet
après-midi la réforme des retraites qui
peut soutenir qu'il ya une réforme des
retraites en france
la personne de la thur durée de
cotisation est un facteur déstabilisant
2000 pour les générations 5 c'est à peu
près ça alors que tout le monde
attendait qu'on ait une vraie décision
de rebâtir un système des retraites qui
soit juste égalitaire est assurée dans
le long terme
alors vous tendez des retraites pour en
parle aussi du budget puisque la
conversation le débat arrive également à
l'assemblée nationale mais nous avons
envoyé on veut dire la conversation vous
voyez qu'un cohérence dans la politique
suivie mais quand même regardons les
chiffres qui apparaissent lors des
débats 10 milliards de ponction
supplémentaire sur les ménages
10 milliards d'allègements sur les
entreprises l'est il ya manifestement
une cohérence le cap économique il est
fixé c'est la politique
je vous auriez fait sur les noms
j'aurais pas du tout agir comme ça sur
les ménages 15 milliards de de ponction
supplémentaire
on peut pas prétendre que ce soit allé
dans le sens que les français souhaitent
et que on leur avait dit alors je vais
vous dire je vais vous dire non non je
vais vous dire ce qu'est ma mad
divergences fondamentales avec françois
hollande avait pour moi il est
impossible de faire des économies si on
ne fait pas des réformes de fond c'est
pas en essayant de couper ici ou là des
des petits millimètres de dépenses
publiques voire quelques millions ici ou
là que vous arriverez à faire les
économies qui se comptent en dizaines de
milliards
vous ne pouvez arriver à ces économies
là que si vous avez reconstruit une
action publique qui doit être à la fois
moins onéreuse et permettez moi de vous
demander d'écouter bien la deuxième
moitié de cette phrase des coques et
plus efficace parce que ce qui est très
frappant quand on regarde l'action
publique de notre pays à la fois état
collectivités locales sécu c'est qu'elle
est très cher et très peu efficaces ou
en tout cas moins efficace qu'on ne
pourrait l'espérer fondamentale qui se
fait pas en un claquement de doigts oui
mais il n'y a eu ni commencement ni
projection de l'avenir il n'y a pas eu
de plans d'architecte quand on
reconstruit maison on fait un plan
d'architecte
rien de tout ça au contraire on accroît
encore tous les défauts du système mais
je vais citer un exemple qui tient à la
maison où vous êtes c'est-à-dire au
sénat et donc collectivités locales une
des rares choses que j'approuvais
vraiment dans le gouvernement précédent
c'était l'idée qu' on allait simplifier
les collectivités locales départements
et régions en particulier en ayant un
seul type d'élu pour les deux assemblées
vous vous souvenez que c'est l'idée que
j'avais proposée dès 2002 et qui avait
été peu à peu reprises par le
gouvernement précédent hors cat ont fait
eh bien on a supprimé cette
simplification pour revenir encore un
peu plus de complexité dans un système
prêt coûte de plus en plus cher et qui
est de moins en moins lisible par le
citoyen j'entends toutes vos critiques
françois bayrou l'avenant vous pouvez
répondre à la question initiale
est-ce que vous avez atteint un point de
non-retour vis-à-vis de françois
hollande jeunes et de jugement par
rapport à l'action des gouvernants qu'en
fonction de ce qu'ils font si un jour
françois hollande ou le gouvernement
prend une attitude que je trouverai une
attitude positive je le dirai quand il
disait je vais faire une autre éthique
de la vie quand il disait je vais faire
une politique de la gelée à prouver
quand il a dit prenant très souvent dit
qu'aujourd'hui ont-ils a dit pas c'est
difficile de tenir ce discours là quand
on est bon et bien prenons un autre
exemple
il avait dit au printemps au mois de mai
je crois et je l'avais à prouver qu' il
allait mettre en place proposer
immédiatement havre est une vraie
intégration politique de la zone euro et
qu'il y aurait une décision politique
qui porterait sur la zone euro ou qui
prendrait en compte les intérêts de la
zone euro et je lai a prouvé de le faire
est-ce que de le dire est ce que ça a
été fait vous qui êtes un observateur
n'attendent en mai ce qui vous laisse
également qu'il n'a pas tenus par
ailleurs j'aime dans vos échanges je me
conversation jamais j'y viens dans une
seconde est
est ce qu il a fait quoi que ce soit
dans le sens de cette affirmation que je
considérais comme une affirmation
positive
rien n'a été fait on n'a pas déposé un
plan sur la table du conseil européen on
s'est contenté quand chaque fois d'une
déclaration purement verbale que les
français intéressés par le sujet pouvait
approuver et qui n'a été suivie de rien
de quoi mais faut le frein majeur c'est
sa majorité présidentielle il aurait dû
vous appeler don jose aurait été
possible
figurez vous que je ne fonctionne pas en
termes de marchandage alors peut-être je
suis minoritaire dans la classe
politique française mais jamais je ne
marchande pas ce que je trouve que c'est
dégradant c'est dévalorisant quelque
chose qui ne qui ne va pas de ce point
de vue là et donc alors programme ça
n'est pas marchander non mais c'est pas
du tout ce qui a été fait en revanche
chaleureux il y avait une promesse
explicite que françois hollande avait
fait quand il m'a écrit entre les deux
tours comme nicolas sarkozy m'avait
écrit cette promesse explicite c'était
qu'il ferait la grande loi de
moralisation de la vie publique dont la
france avait besoin
et il avait ajouté quelque chose d'autre
qui était que s'il y avait des freins au
parlement devant le cumul des mandats
devant le financement de la vie publique
devant je ne sais quoi toutes les
opérations nécessaires alors ils iraient
au référendum du peuple français
quand at il fait alors rien et on
constate et je ne sais pas si vous avez
remarqué françois bayrou mais des
responsables socialistes et non des
moindres vous regrette aujourd'hui
françois rebsamen le patron des
sénateurs socialistes étaient à votre
place il ya quelques semaines il a dit
il a regretté que des gestes envers vous
n'ait pas été fait et puis manuel valls
juge embêtant votre départ de la
majorité présidentielle c'est comme ça
qu'un express présente les choses cette
semaine le ministre d'intérieur dit que
françois hollande avait plutôt envie de
faire des gestes en votre direction
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux jurés
leur gré
non je pense qu'il ya une erreur de de
perspectives je n'ai jamais soutenu où
je n'ai jamais apporté ou donner du
crédit à françois hollande en fonction
de gestes pas besoin de gestes jeu
responsable politique qui est un exemple
il ya tellement con et mines candidat
socialiste en face de vous en
législatives de l'an dernier c'est trop
tard maintenant évidemment c'est facile
mais donc il regrette de vous voir
partir mais je n'en joue l'opposition
que répondez-vous aux humanos il aurait
pu mal idée en tête c'est que je n'ai
jamais changé de ligne
j'ai fait crédit en attendant que le
gouvernement le pouvoir
accomplissez changer de pied accor va
mal laissez moi n'ont en aucune manière
à bon et je voudrais que vous si vous le
pouvez aller que vous entendiez sur un
agent vous dit j'ai un certain nombre de
certitudes sur ce qu'il faut faire pour
la france
les années précédentes étaient des
années à mon avis de d'inquiétantes
glissement des rives et je pensais que
françois hollande allait respecter les
engagements qu'il avait pris je pensais
même qu'il avait sur ce sujet des atouts
particuliers que les autres n'avaient
pas d'abord parce qu'il était plus en
phase avec le monde syndical par exemple
ils pouvaient proposer des réformes plus
ambitieuses et puis c'était un pouvoir
nouveau après beaucoup d'années de
difficultés je pensais qu'il avait des
atouts et la grille la grille et ses 1
tc a tout à mon avis ne les a pas joués
alors vous demander pourquoi c'est
intéressant comme question je pense
parce qu'il a les yeux trop fixé sur sa
majorité
je pense que ce qu'il rêve intéresse ce
qu'il a en tête ce qui le
le en tout le perturbe ce sont les états
d'âme des courants du parti qui le
soutient et des alliés du parti que le
soutien et des satellites du parti qu'il
soutient et je pense que c'est une
erreur de conception de la fonction
présidentielle tout faire voler en
éclats non mais écoutez moi bien
il est président de la république il a
perdu nageurs et grenier ministre il
n'est pas premier ministre c'est le
premier ministre qui s'occupe de la
majorité d'accord le dans les
institutions de la vème république le
chef de la majorité c'est le premier
ministre est toujours dans les
institutions de la vème république
l'homme qui s'occupe du pays et pas du
parti des enjeux du pays
pas de la communication mais du fond
c'est le président de la république et
pour moi il n'est pas une une relique
il n'a pas pris à bâle à bras le corps
la responsabilité présidentielle comme
il aurait dû le faire avec cette vision
qui est celle que qui s'imposent lorsque
leur peuple vous a donné sa conf leur le
peuple justement vous avez vu nouveau
record d'impopularité pour le chef de
l'état 24% d'opinions favorables selon
ipsos seulement parce que cela pose la
question de la légitimité de l'exécutif
question que pose par exemple
l'ump christian jacob non je trouve
ridicules les accusations réciproques de
l'ump du ps sur vous êtes responsable de
marine le pen disent les uns ou bien
vous avez perdu toute légitimité disent
les autres c'est avait critiqué ce test
comme l'a dit bruno le maire attendu
qu'elle ça devient difficile de
gouverner est encore plus de réformes
il y à un seuil critique au dessous
duquel il est très difficile de
gouverner ça n'est pas une raison pour
faire un procès en légitimité parce que
évidemment sanaa ça n'a aucun sens je
vais vous dire ce que je pense de la
popularité
pour moi la bcrg d'ailleurs vu
changement de clairoix l'impopularité
ça n'a aucune importance si on fait des
choses qui comptent
il arrive que des gouvernants doivent
assumer l'impopularité si ils font pour
leur pays ce qui doit être fait des
choses importantes lourde qui
probablement dérange mais ils le font
mais l'impopularité quand on ne fait pas
ce qu'il faut faire
alors ça c'est très embêtant et ça
empêche de pouvoir entrer dans l'action
politique la plus profonde celle qui
pour l'instant n'est pas conduite
alors on va parler du centre de
l'extrême droite également vous l'avez
évoqué d'un mot françois bayrou avec
raphaël hermano de l' agence
france-presse qui va nous rejoindre
l'élection de brignoles mark en effet
l'avènement apparemment du tri patte du
tripartisme c'est en tous les cas ce que
dit le socialiste jean christophe
cambadélis et c'est vous faut-il le
rappeler qu'ils poursuivent y ait ce but
à mettre fin au bipartisme et bien
marine le pen semble y parvenir sophie
normand ni droite ni gauche françois
bayrou voulait faire éclater le
bipartisme et se poser en troisième
homme mais voilà que marine le pen vient
lui ravir la place
en témoigne la victoire du front
national à brignoles dimanche dernier ce
qui est intéressant c'est pas tellement
la victoire électorale du front national
c'est que le front national c'est nier
au centre de la vie politique française
et qui va être l'enjeu des prochaines
élections
partisme le mot est lâché marine le pen
sincère peu à peu dans le clivage gauche
droite et évince françois bayrou de
l'échiquier politique
en politique on hérite jamais de rien
les places qu'on a c'est ça le comprend
et françois bayrou a perdu la sienne à
gauche comme à droite de manuel valls à
françois fillon le fn est devenu une
obsession selon le mot de sa présidente
marine le pen qui peut s'appuyer sur un
parti solide là où françois bayrou a
échoué son capital politique c'est
uniquement la notoriété qu'il avait
acquise à la fois en tant qu ancien
candidat du centre à l'élection
présidentielle en 2002 et d'autre part
sa critique du sarkozysme
une seule solution pour faire éclater le
bipartisme la prochaine élection
présidentielle françois bayrou aura-t-il
l'audace de se présenter une nouvelle
fois
réponse dans quatre ans voilà raphaël
hermano est avec nous rappelle bonsoir
vos questions à françois bayrou
alors françois bayrou bonjour fin du
tripartisme marine le pen a réussi là où
vous avez échoué non en aucune manière
le ce que je me suis fixé comme but dans
la vie politique c'est que notre pays
puisse prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent et retrouvé par son action
propre son indépendance sa liberté de
manoeuvre
le le rayonnement qui devrait être le
sien la richesse pour ses concitoyens
l'avenir pour ces jeunes et l'emploi et
si vous me dites que c'est ce que marine
le pen apporte à la france
alors permettez moi de dire
parmi les objectifs il y avait celui de
peu d'en face confond blé aux partis
confondus même chose vous comprendez
quelque chose qui est qui et
presque navrant il faut faire attention
vous confondez les moyens et les fins et
les bus le but c'est que notre pays se
porte mieux pour qu'ils se portent mieux
il faut qu'il puisse faire une politique
de réformes pour qu'il fasse une
politique de réforme il faut qu'il ait
une majorité différente de celle qui est
la sienne aujourd'hui c'est je vais vous
dire ça gentiment et avec beaucoup de
respect naturellement pour l'éminente
fonctions et les qualités hors du commun
qui sont les vôtres femmes journalistes
mais vous êtes je crois fasciné par les
sondages qu'obtiennent les uns ou les
autres
ça n'est pas la bonne moins que d'autres
ça n'est pas la bonne dont je parle pas
de vous ici
ça n'aura pas élections au mois bien
élection après élection que le front
national gagne du terrain donc la
question se pose légitimement de savoir
si on arrive vers et bien si tu as eu
permettez moi de poser la question
différente
la question différemment excusez moi
c'est que la seule question qui se pose
c'est est-ce que ce que vous décrivez
est bon pour le pays ou mauvais pour le
pays ça c'est vous qui répondent non non
nous avons à répondre tous en citoyens
ceux des citoyens comme les autres il ya
eu tout un temps où les journalistes
éditorialisé comme on dit sont ce genre
de sujets là pour vous interroger ce que
vous dites on a l'impression que vous
jugez au fond que la presse notamment
parle peut-être trop du front national
est ce que c'est ce que c'est à travers
ça c'est autre chose
fascination bon non sans doute oui mais
ça n'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est que
les responsables politiques peut en tout
cas ne perdent pas de vue la seule
question qui se pose est ce que tout ça
nous amène à du mieux
ou est ce que tout ça nous amène à du
pire et bien pour moi la réponse est
sans ambiguïté
ça nous amène à de graves accidents
parce que pour deux raisons très très
importante
la première
vous savez que j'ai eu de longs débats
avec nicolas sarkozy sur ce sujet la
responsabilité première d'un chef d'état
ou d'un homme politique majeure la
responsabilité première c'est l'unité de
son pays de son peuple
si il dresse les uns contre les autres
il rend le pire des services à son pays
là vous accréditent sa accrédités à
trois disques dis ça parce que j'avais
pas fini mais quand même j'ai eu l'air
de vous estimez que effectivement que
c'est des rebelles l'ump a sa part de
responsabilité dans la poussée du front
national a sa part de responsabilité
vous avez été très dur pendant la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy sur la
droite y va ce qu'il sait jamais employé
le mot droitisation non mais vous n'êtes
pas ce que le mot droitisation voudrait
dire que la droite c'est mal et je n'ai
jamais pensé moi que la droite c'était
mal car il ya une droite que je
considère et des valeurs de droite que
je considère comme absolument honorable
l'honneur le sens du travail lé
dévouement
le sentiment que au fond on est
responsable de son propre destin pour
d'entités nationales par exemple vous
n'en vouliez pas non et est-ce que vous
poserez la question différemment est ce
que l'ump est ce que l'ump petit à petit
at à banaliser les idées du front
national de bon vous voyez bien qu'il ya
une course que que tout le monde va les
combats politiques ont toujours lieu à
la frontière entre deux forces
et donc comme le combat est à la
frontière en masse les troupes à la
frontière
et comme en masse les troupes à la
frontière et bien on se base sur les
mots même les idées mêmes qui sont
celles de l'adversaire le plus voisins
et donc de ce point de vue là oui il ya
cette emprise mais je n'ai jamais
employé le mot droitisation accord et
donc je veux je veux simplement revenir
à la deuxième partie de la question est
donc la première partie c'était sa
division il ya une deuxième part de
responsabilité qui je considère qui fait
que je considère que le front national
conduit non pas du mieux mais du pire
c'est que les idées qu'ils propagent
sont des idées mortel si on se mêlaient
de les appliquer par exemple la france
hors de l'europe elle sort de l'euro
elle elle renvoie on voit pas bien
comment les immigrés elle supprime
et bien tout cela pour moi je pense que
ça conduit à de graves accidents et donc
voilà les deux pôles qui font que pour
ma part je suis en effet en absolu
opposition assez cette force alors ça
pose par ailleurs la question du front
républicain on a vu qu'il avait plus que
du plomb dans l aile à l'occasion de
cette élection de brignoles est ce que
vous vous y êtes toujours favorables ou
est-ce qu'il est mort définitivement
enterré je sais pas ce que c'est parce
que tout le monde annonce semaine après
semaine que le front républicain c'est
fini l'ump a dit plus jamais de front
républicain il m'a semblé que à
brignoles il espérait d'avoir avoir les
voix de gauche n'est ce pas oui non et
donc il y avait là comme une
contradiction
certains ténors y avait des visions n'ya
pas division ce temps est révolu
ils ont eu beaucoup de voix de gauche
c'est même ce qui a permis la remontée
de la candidate mais je pense qu'en
effet il ya quelque chose d'eux devrait
et qui n'est pas en taule au moins en
terme de messages qui n'est pas un bon
message c'est de dire tous contre le
front national
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est tous contre
les causes du front national est la
première des causes du front national
c'est l'impuissance dans laquelle les
deux majorités successives aux deux
autour des deux partis principaux
successifs s'est trouvé enfermé
l'absence de résultats comme des
françois hollande s'est même pas de
résultats c'est l'absence de décision si
des décisions courageuses avaient été
prises on pourrait parler des résultats
mais aucune décision courageuse de prix
lors il faut rêver car c'est un joueur
de vous demander françois bayrou ce que
vous faites en cas de duel hollande
marine le pen je n'ai aucune intention
de me placer dans l'hypothèse d'un duel
hollande marine le pen que je trouve
aujourd'hui très improbable avant pour
refuser de répondre et je vous voyez que
tous les responsables publics que vous
inviter à cette table qui s'était rendu
spontanément ya et bien moi ce que je
souhaite avec avec constance c'est qu'on
ne se trouve pas dans ce type d'
hypothèse est envisagé l'hypothèse c'est
accréditer l'hypothèse vous voyez le un
monsieur que qu'est ce que vous ferez en
cas de duel je ne sais pas mélenchon
marine le pen est bien excusez moi de
vous dire que je trouve
l'hypothèse peu crédible et je n'ai pas
envie d'une manière ou d'une autre
d'accréditer cette hypothèse est donc je
leur fais je trouve non nous avons n'est
pas répondre je trouve que on n'a pas à
se placer dans les hypothèses de
questions d'accord que vous posez sous
sa défense non réponse raphael du fn il
ya aussi le centre vous en tant que
patron du modem vous êtes en train de
vous rapprocher de lui dit jean louis
borloo contre l inverse de l'escap à une
petite contradiction après tout ce que
vous avez dit sur nicolas sarkozy
pendant cinq ans à vous rapprocher de
quelqu'un qui a été l'un de ses
principaux ministres pendant trois ans
et la même faille est son premier
ministre ont failli alors revenons une
seconde à ce que vous dites pour qu'on
voit si ça tient
1 vous n'ignorez pas que j'ai de très
bonnes relations avec un à juppé vous
étonne ça ne m'étonne pas travailler va
nager a été ministre des affaires
étrangères de nicolas sarkozy je ne
considère pas qui est le la moindre
contamination des uns par les autres
il est rare qu ise quoi jean louis
borloo c'est mon nom me suis pas ça la
question la question est que je n'ai
dans ma vie aucun plan politique pour
que cette majorité nouvelle puisse
apparaître et que la politique nouvelle
puisse être faite il faut qu' un centre
en france à condition que ce centre soit
indépendant sûrs de ce qu'ils pensent et
jean louis borloo ayant quitté l'ump et
tous ceux qui l'entourent 10 ans en font
maintenant avec sans abandonner ses
alliances à mais on a le droit d'avoir
des alliances on a le droit
la seule condition c'est que les
alliances ne soient pas automatiques
quelles que soient les décisions les
orientations prises moi je
je n'ai aucune difficulté à avoir des
alliances avec la droite c'est pour
quand on veut savoir maintenant
pardonnez moi mais je trouve qu'il faut
choisir les mots et franchement entre
jean-louis borloo et moi ce ce
vocabulaire matrimoniale de l'autre non
mais le le rapprochement la construction
d'une maison commune qui est nécessaire
pour que les deux familles du centre
puisse vivre et travailler ensemble
ben j'espère que c'est dans les dix
jours qui viennent
les légeoises apprenant ça prendrait
quelle forme et vous verrez on vous
invitera vous serez content vous
découvrirez comme ça ça vous permet de
faire des hypothèses d'imaginer ce qu'on
pourrait faire d'être surpris par la
simplicité des choses de mon goût par
exemple sur les européennes comment
est-ce que ça va se passer y aura des
listes communes
udi modem à le la première décision qui
découle de cet accord ou de ce
rapprochement s'est évidemment qui est
des listes communes entre les deux
familles du son pour les municipales
s'est passé comment parce que là c'est
un peu différent accord à peu près sur
90% des sur 90% des villes et 10% c'est
là vous avez vous des alliances avec la
gauche non un enfant ça dépend il ya des
cas où nous avons des listes nous sur
des communes y compris qui nous
appartiennent et où lui dit jusqu'à
maintenant était dans une alliance avec
l'ump dont on peut discuter de ces de
c2c reconfiguration mais vous
conserverez des alliances à gauche pour
les prochaines municipales on peut citer
daredevil l'épaule
les gens aux cantonales elle veut garder
son bras il est jusqu'à maintenant n'a
été décidé a et donc je vais vous dire
les choses comme je le pense depuis
longtemps je pense que ceux qui
devraient gouverner les élections
locales c'est la personnalité des
responsables locaux élections locales
mais lui dit valentin on a on a des
discussions il ya des réglages c'est
tout à fait normal à paris comment ça va
se passer quand marielle de sarnez va
être sur une liste derrière vous lui
poserez la question
j'ai quelques idées mais je ne pense que
je pense que ce que marielle de sarnez
fait précisément dans la logique de ce
que sur quoi vous m'interrogez c'est
rassembler le centre pour qu'il pèse à
paris et après je pense qu'elle envisage
y compris des rassemblements plus large
mais c'est elle qui le dira c'est pas
moi est ce que vous croyez inéluctable
des accords à la base entre l'ump et le
front national vous avez vu ça
correspond à la tente à la demande des
sympathisants je pense qu'il ya une
pression très importante sur ce sujet
j'espère que l'ump y résistera
d'ailleurs pas seulement l'ump il peut y
avoir ici ou là des tentations de ce
genre moi en tout cas je recommanderais
et je ferai tout ce que je peux pour
qu'on me pour qu'on y cèdent pas est ce
que une aiguille et modem vous irait
jusqu'à présenter un candidat commun à
la présidentielle
je vous ai dit que la première décision
qui découle s étaient les européennes et
la deuxième soirée cool et d'un an
là deux non voyants faut écouter c'est
le le problème de votre vocation de
journaliste c'est que les questions
c'est important mais je vous dis un
secret les réponses aussi à les écouter
et donc pour moi je ne vous dis
nullement chaque chose en son temps je
vous dis que dans l'accord il y aura
forcément l'orientation de présenter un
candidat le jour venu à l'élection
présidentielle bien qu'on ne sache pas
qui c'est pour vous éviter les
obsessions
mais une grande famille politique à
vocation à présenter un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
soyez prêts pour a rempilé pour le
quatrième que je n'ai absolument pas ça
dans ma ligne de mire ah bon m eur
plonger quand même je nomme je vous
réponds non pas dans votre lit ou
peut-être 20 dans votre ligue lettre
vous entendez pas c'est ici je n'ai bien
entendu lié alors dites-nous vous devez
crier ça n'est pas normal in avant les
européennes avant la présidentielle il
ya donc les municipales et vous vous
replonger enfin vous repartez au combat
à pompe et bien à vous pouvez vous avez
déjà entendu ma réponse alors je vais la
faire aussi calmement que possible c'est
une affaire de ses affaires d'une ville
qu'est la ville de pau qui se trouve
elle n'a pas le droit de mettre la ville
dans laquelle j'ai passé ma vie à
laquelle j'ai été grandi dans la chaîne
de j'ai mes enfants et ma famille a eu
sa gyger merci de me faire de l'audience
et à djalal ville qui m'intéressent
profondément dont je pense qu'elle va
mal et quand j'aurai à en parler
j'en parlerai à pau opale on est
d'accord à pau très bien quand même
alors direction ump localement non mais
du coup à l'ump a fait comprendre que
elle maintiendrait coûte que coûte une
liste à pau donc en gros ils veulent
vous faire payer le votre boulanger à 6
ans est ce que c est ce que c'est ça qui
vous empêcherait que est ce que vous
vous souvenez qu'ils ont déjà
c'est ça ya six ans mais que ce n'était
pas pour la raison du deuxième tour de
2012 et donc c'est un acharnement et
donc je je je suis à peu près certain
que les esprits sur ce sujet doivent
évoluer parce qu'autrement ça voudrait
dire que c'est la volonté de perdre
cette ville qui appartient au parti
socialiste permettez moi de vous le dire
depuis 42 ans
ce qui fait tout de même un bail